geisteskrank es ist wirklich
geisteskranken die deutschen rating ist
mittlerweile so etwas wie ein fester
bestandteil von diesem kanal leute die
haben einige videos von ihr gesehen
gekrönt wir haben gedacht wir haben
unsere eigene existenz hinterfragt und
ganz ehrlich leute wenn ich ganz ehrlich
bin habe ich eben ja auch kein interesse
daran mehr mir neue videos von der
einzuziehen
wisst ihr warum leute die macht immer
noch das gleich immer noch seit gefühlt
drei jahren macht sie drei uhr nachts
videos und öffne um 3 und nachts niemals
halloween frozen adventskalender lesung
83 das verfluchte liebesbriefe von
talking tom cat keine sorge wir haben
schon gesehen gehen wir heute nicht in
diese richtung ich dachte nämlich
letztes mal so was könnte man eigentlich
machen und da habe ich mir gesagt ist es
nicht spannend zuschauen wie rebecca
ring früher war wir wissen wie sie heute
nichts mehr wissen was gerade passiert
ist aber wie war sie früher bei ihren
ersten videos das schauen was heute an
let's go das älteste videos von becker
bin jetzt gerade angezeigt bekommen kann
lautet tutorial die eier alltags make up
für schule 2016 fünf minuten als rein
[Musik]
gar nicht verträumt
wo ist also der schock steht mir ins
gesicht geschrieben auf jeden fall
können wir schon mal erkennen dass eine
relativ krasse veränderung stattgefunden
hat im laufe der zeit bei ihr und ihre
ersten videos sind wirklich einfach zu
klassische schminkt videos
[Musik]
dann haben wir wirklich alles aus einer
ganz anderen zeit also es wird man
schaut wirklich dieses video an und man
fragt sich jeder was darf ich denn jetzt
um drei uhr nachts nicht machen mit wem
soll ich 33 uhr nachts nicht facetime
welche verfluchte puppe verfolgt mich
jetzt in den wald und es wird einem
einfach nicht gesagt
[Musik]
oh ja also das wird auf jeden fall ganz
ganz ganz krasser kontrast gern daneben
schon ein bisschen nennenswerten
vertrags schon sehen können bisher aber
der kontrast wird mit sicherheit noch
größer jetzt fragen sich ein paar von
euch vielleicht sowie wie ging diese
entwicklung von staaten von damals
tutorials die zu diesen drei uhr nachts
videos und dazu kann ich euch sagen
leute auf youtube passieren einige dinge
fünf jahre sind eine verdammt lange zeit
vor fünf jahren habe ich meinen ersten
minecraft videos hochgeladen
geht das war vor sieben jahren und man
entwickelt sich einfach weiter man geht
auch mit der zeit und dann das ist jetzt
schauen wir jetzt ihr weg von der weißt
du ja dem passiert heute macht habe ich
mein tag für euch krass krass das ist
wirklich geisteskrank unterstützt wo sie
mal gesprochen hat leute das ist
wirklich stick leute gebt euch das hier
redet wirklich komplett normal mit so
einem leichten so leicht ist gering so
wie sich so gibt relativ normaler ton es
ist wirklich ein unterschied wie himmel
und erde zu den heutigen videos ich
versuche es einfach mal ganz wertfrei zu
formulieren so in den in diesen 83 ist
die sie seit jahren da macht ist ja
immer so und soviel aufgedreht habe
gefühlt auf die gekünstelte als erste
station
ok ich muss manchmal gedanken mal
aussprechen den ich gerade im kopf habe
dieses video dient auch gar nicht dem
zweck auf sie als personen irgendwie
einzudreschen oder so aber ganz im
gegenteil leute das hier zeigt auch so
wissen jetzt den weg auf wie sich so ein
youtube über die zeit entwickelt
konzepte was ich meine weil ich glaube
man ist geneigt gerade auch ihr und ich
auch irgendwo nur das zusehen wo eine
person heute ist also weißt du so
wedding sie machte wie drei uhr nachts
videos es ist hanebüchen ist es verrückt
man denkt sich was ist da los aber man
denkt in diesem moment gar nicht über
die person vor der kamera nach und man
denkt auch nicht über die geschichte
dieser person nach will mir jetzt diese
videos von ihr sehen anstatt diese drei
weihnachts videos würden wir ganz anders
von ihr denken also das war wirklich
schon krass leute das wirklich heftiger
himmelweiter unterschied aber
letztendlich ist das hier auch ein
schwenk video wusste nicht so viel zu
sehen gibt am ende deswegen schauen wir
mal auf ihr zweitältestes video das da
lautet tipps gegen langeweile hilft
wirklich live hacks werbung da waren
übrigens leute das fällt mir auch gerade
auf die titel auch noch anders also das
ist ja auch so ein merkmal von ihr dass
ihre titel manchmal so bist du ein
bisschen yoga mäßig klingen in der art
und weise wie die formuliert sind dass
auch anders geisteskrank es ist wirklich
geisteskrank geisteskrank es ist ein
himmelweiter unterschied und das ist
wirklich auch für mich spannend leute
ich gehe davon aus dass es für euch auch
so spannend dass ich hoffe es zumindest
weil leute das ist ja eine person über
die wir wirklich schon iks videos
gemacht haben wir haben uns amüsiert
manchmal waren wir ein bisschen zu hart
manchmal waren wir rasch genug und haben
auch zu recht kritisiert und die ganze
war dass du diese eine person check dem
was ich meine
die drei wissen was diese übertreibt und
so und das ist einfach das ist wirkt
mehr wie ein normaler mensch auf mich ja
wissen was meine kraft also wenn ihr
meine halten wie es antrag heute dann
bin ich auch deutlich ruhiger ihr seht
nicht nur mein gesicht immerhin erstmals
so also müssen wir darüber muss man
nicht drüber reden aber es ist crazy man
sieht ihr tatsächlich die nervosität an
in diesen videos also man sieht wie sie
den druck der kamera quasi spürt dass
etwas was man als youtube natürlich auch
erst mit der zeit ab legt also wirklich
manchmal löschen youtube also ihre ganz
halten wie es aber das muss wirklich
eines der ersten gewesen sein so von der
art und weise ja denn der visite mit der
sie spricht es ist wirklich gut gemacht
das video ist gut gemacht wenn das
wirklich eines der ersten von den
spielern aufgrund ihrer art ausgeht muss
man sagen das sind gute chance das ist
ein gut produziertes video da kann man
nichts sagen okay also was kochen was
kann man noch machen
das ist gut gemacht wenn dann auch das
lesen ein bisschen muss man sagen also
die die tipps an sich sind ja relativ
simpel gehalten sag ich mal also die ich
würde mal sagen die meisten menschen
kommen darauf dass irgendwas lesen
können oder musik hören können was
kochen können wenn ihnen langweilig ist
einerseits gut wem ist jetzt so wirklich
langweilig in dieser art und weise
wahrscheinlich er auch so schulkindern
oder sowas vielleicht kommt ja auch
nicht so direkt drauf einer den nächsten
punkt ist sollte auch filme gucken dass
in sachen also kann ich mittlerweile
aussetzen zu selbst zu denken aber crazy
alter crazy und dass man so die erste
videos das war nur so drei videos
letzter minute lass mir etwas zum
vatertag machen morgen routine was in
meiner tasche und dann ging es
irgendwann lose mit wisst ihr leute
genau sowas find ich geil man hat die
ganze zu einem blickwinkel auf
irgendeine sache oder irgendeine person
und dann sieht man was ganz neues und
das eröffnete eine neue perspektive auf
dinge oder auch ganze personen ist nicht
mehr geil ich hoffe halt auch spaß dabei
deutet die kritieren vorgeschlagen das
video hier oben könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren schreibt mir die kommentare
was ihr davon haltet ihr dieses video
aufgenommen habt also ich hab das video
aufgenommen
ja das ist gruselig